today's topics there's a little bit of
YouTube stuff that unfolded recently a
girl who's a popular streamer online
okay had a boyfriend she was flirting
with another streamer often you know
they hinted at a relationship stuff like
that they were doing it very publicly
made everyone think problem is she
didn't tell anybody that she had a
boyfriend okay
getting shady led this guy on right even
though they were long-distance they went
on a couple dates you know but she kept
letting him on but she never you know
went the full way with them mm-hmm
here's where it gets interesting man a
is always in the closet she's kept there
okay now she got plan B okay plan B is
out in the public big name she's
mooching okay then she sleeps with Plan
B's friend who's Plan C okay now guess
what what apparently there's a plan B
who didn't know about none of these
plans and he was always playing a so he
was giving her that D the little did he
know he was plan D lots of people
involved lots of plans everybody finds
out about the other plans
and you know when you plan B and you
thought you was playing in you man
if you want to be playing a but when you
plan B have you thought you was playing
hey G whoa you cheese too so all the
plans were made out of the other plans
as well as the girl who was making the
plans the plans were mad at the other
plans plan never be mad at the plane
right because plan B was mad at Plan C
because that was his best friend's I do
Plan C how you gonna be plan see when
you know I'm trying to be plan a you
know I'm saying Mo's that makes sense I
feel okay so everything blew up okay no
she's the only one that blew here's her
apology video oh I don't want to be
honest my relationship with Carson was
very complicated I had a boyfriend at
the time and neither Carson nor my
boyfriend at the time knew about each
other
and while I was clear with Carson that
Carson and I were not in a relationship
I still led him on and ended up hurting
Carson and my boyfriend at the time very
badly in the process I am now seeing a
therapist and although I didn't realize
it at the time I was dealing a lot with
depersonalization and I felt like I was
two different people
living two different lives I feel like a
passenger in my own body I ignored very
conflicting feelings and thoughts and I
was very lost and confused and I didn't
know what I wanted or what was important
to me and this was when I got involved
with Fitz and I handled it very
similarly to how I handled previous
things I depersonalized a lot and was
very lost and confused and didn't know
what I wanted and made a lot of bad
decisions because of that and I was lost
and confused and I ended up hurting
people that I cared about and in the
future I want to be better and I want to
focus on myself which is why I'm taking
further time off streaming and I'm
working through my depersonalization I'm
still seeing my therapist and I want to
live my life more openly and honestly
and more than anything I want to be
honest with myself which is something
that I've struggled with a lot and I'm
sorry to everyone I'm sorry too I'm
sorry to my community and anyone that
I've disappointed or let down I'm sorry
to Carson's community I'm sorry a Fitz's
community and anyone else's community
was affected by this anyone know how to
deal with this drama and their chat I'm
sorry to tempo then bringing them
because what I hear is always it was not
my fault that wasn't me that was biology
that's what I hear that's why I always
hear have some very valid what you're
saying is real and very well-intentioned
what I hear I'm sorry but it was not my
fault that's always what I hear and to
me that's a half-assed apology it wasn't
her fault
it was my allergy I know I know but
still if you say you're sorry
you that is sorry I think that it's
interesting that whenever I hear these
apology tours there's always a therapist
that becomes involved there's always a
mental health issue that becomes a
quality time there's always a donation
that follows that something hard
these are the rules nobody would have
been hurt if you just kept that to
yourself I don't know man I have a
problem with people's over sharing my
things with the views it's you know it's
always been a problem with me we had a
public relationship you know that they
share with their fans yes but I don't I
do not get there's one thing about
hiding it that's one thing that's one
degree there's one thing about just
living your life and doing your thing
but what they did was advertising it and
making the thing
it's cringy to me it's a big cringe
there's a lot of crazy stuff from
advertising your relationship to saying
you're sorry like that if you say you're
sorry say you're sorry hey I thought if
you have to say you're sorry it should
be like you said an 8-second video you
get there you say I'm sorry I messed up
I need to do better
end of story because now you're see
making it seem like people would
depersonalized will always engage in
this kind of behavior or it explains
their behavior there's plenty of people
who have that condition who don't do
things nearly as bad as you right and it
does sound like you're copping out from
taking responsibility it really sounds
like that I got so many questions oh how
are you a public figure do you do public
strings with some other dude y'all
flirtin talking about y'all going on
date soon and your boyfriend does it I
don't know how you don't have public
relationships when you got a boyfriend
how you gonna keep him in the dark for
something you're streaming online
publicly to hundreds of thousands of
people
that's dumb to be and nobody's in that's
dumb to me it's like going on a reality
TV show or there's cameras set up every
wall with your husband and then sleeping
with another contestant and be like how
did we get caught there's cameras
everywhere you think you're the
Invisible Woman like what did you think
was gonna happen
that [ __ ] yes has to be is not you know
what it is at the end of the day some
people want to extract benefits from
other people and either aid their
maliciously doing it where they want to
hurt the people around them or be
they're just reckless because they don't
care or they're just not able to
actually do properly success either way
this person is an idiot right because if
you're maliciously doing it you're doing
it stupidly or if you're doing it
recklessly well then you're an idiot
because you're gonna get in trouble and
it's gonna backfire easy right so
regardless I'm looking at this like how
dumb do you have to be and then you're
gonna sleep with the best ran out like
the best friend who's also a streamer
and a public figure and now she's seeing
a therapist hopefully she's not banging
him - but you Betty and then the best
friend that's some trash for you to know
that your boy is mad interested no girl
like head over heels for and then you
smash and you do it behind closed doors
and you don't say nothing and it comes
out as a big drama that's trash on your
part we agree agreed okay agreed if you
never even smashed I don't care even if
he hoped to high heaven if you're really
good friends with him and you know it's
gonna crush him don't do it maybe it was
just like there being you know
sympathetic to just me it's really the
apology that got me there is it a drama
I mean maybe I'm just being petty but
it's just interesting to me like so
these guys are like big streamers make
millions a year right do really well for
themselves financially mhm
and it's just interested in me that
they're all caught up in some drama over
an average broad with very little skills
do you know what I'm saying someone like
that could cause that much turmoil
fascinates as far as the lack of
accountability goes I mean I'm not
surprised what do you expect a lot of
people don't have much character
someone who strung you along and kept
you in the dark and kept getting the
goods from you while giving you very
little in return
you're surprised that that person
doesn't take accountability it's like
there's just more evidence that a lot of
people are not very good judge of
character do you do what I'm saying yeah
for you to be that involved with someone
for that long and to be that duped um
he's just thoughts that I was running
through my head I can't do anything
about people who are manipulative and
[ __ ] liars
right it's just like people who say
stuff like why you telling my daughter
to do this you should tell men not to
not to Weinstein people I'm like listen
Weinstein's are gonna exist whether we
like it or not we're not gonna eradicate
crime from the world but we can do is
engage in pre-emptive measures in order
to make sure that we're safe yeah
make sense so I think instead of telling
people don't be deceiving what I'm
telling people is I learn to look out
for Josh yeah learn to look out for
people who are gonna string you along
and waste your time I'm gonna try to
control what I can control exactly I
cannot control the amount of bad that's
in the world I control that no I'm gonna
try to control me being safe or taking
miseries right the dream would be utopia
would be to tell my daughter I don't
have a daughter but if I would have
you're a woman you can walk the streets
naked and nothing should happen to you
sure but the reality is not that my job
as a father is to have my little girl
come back home safe so I'm gonna tell
her and give her all the tools she needs
to not be in that position that's all I
could so just looking at what I have
here yeah I can't do a detailed sitrep
of everything the girl did that may have
indicated or tipped Emma what I do tell
people is when you go through something
terrible like this where you do get
cheated on or first thing you want to do
is to help yourself move on the second
thing you want to do is also to look
back and look at some of the things that
you might have missed that may have
indicated to you that you were dealing
with something bad reflection and that
internalizing what you've learned is
going to help you with future instances
does that make sense it's like when when
there's a car accident what do they do
they do an investigation they find out
what happened and then they adjust the
cars so the cars in the future are
better math safer same thing you can do
with your own experience so at the end
of the day what
I tell people's like if you go through
something like this please just take the
time to self-reflect take the time to
heal your wounds and take the time to
learn from what happened but I'll just
move on to the next experience don't try
to burn yourself away from it learn
internalize understand what it is you
may have missed and if you can't see it
if you just really can't then have some
friends join it right talking to other
people can help you to see some of the
stuff that you're missing because most
of the stuff that I've been through with
people that have been negative right
especially early on my dating life and I
didn't know nothing mm-hmm I could have
avoided had I known the signs and
because I learned those signs I avoided
those negative into interactions and now
like I'm not dealing with the problems
with women that I was when I was 20 that
I am now about 29 I would caution you
guys to look out for those things and
this is not just applicable to dating
it's applicable to business relationship
jobs I mean if you always get fired from
jobs you have to reflect on what you're
doing what is the thing that's going on
you have to suffrage flecked I was at a
point in my life where I was in that
position not always the people sometimes
you are making people act a certain way
during that if they're the thing that
repeats itself all the time like it
keeps on repeating itself to you the
common denominator is you got to look at
yourself you have to look at what you're
doing you have to see the signs of
what's going on and what is helping you
or not helping you're putting you in
that predicament I'm not saying that
every time it is always your fault
but there's some answers there you have
a job to stop going the right way and
it's always like that it's not all the
jobs mmm people don't like you or you
have a hard time having relationships or
stuff like that you have a hard time
having relationship you have a hard time
everything it's not everybody and if
it's everybody it's still everybody that
you choose but beyond that if you're
going to just sit with it's the people
around me you know then what ends up
happening is you take away your own
and you give it to others yeah anyways
let us know what you guys think in the
blog was this the smartest infidelity
you've ever seen anyone so dumb isn't it
[Music]